es ist früh am Morgen in Marseille Theo
macht sich auf in die Schule vor ihm
liegen Mauern Gitter Absperrungen
Theos Bildungsweg ist ein Hindernislauf
und sein Vater entsprechend sauer
und der Brandis geboren muss Risiken
eingehen nur um in die Schule zu gehen
und pünktlich anzukommen ansonsten
müsste viel früher aufstehen und viel
früher aus dem Haus
sie stellt sich Theo und vielen anderen
in den Weg eine Mauer errichtet von der
Wohnanlage nebenan und schwer zu
überwinden die ausgeschlossenen haben
gebeten dass man eine Tür für Sie
einbaue die Nachbarn haben abgelehnt
ihr noch schön erst
unseren Kindern zeigt man so von klein
auf dass man sich von ihnen fernhalten
wenn man von klein auf wie ein Gauner
behandelt wird
dann benimmt man sich irgendwann
Marseille geht hinter die Barrikaden ein
Grund Angst vor Kriminalität 28 getötete
im Drogen Milieu zählt Marseille bis
Anfang Oktober immer wieder werden Autos
angezündet Teile geklaut Wohnungen
aufgebrochen
Pascal Jena ist Hausmeister und Wächter
er zeigt uns ein Gelände mit
Eigentumswohnungen neue Gitter und
Barrieren sollen nur noch Bewohner
durchlassen
ich habe die Entwicklung im Viertel
Schritt für Schritt beobachtet sowie die
Wohnanlagen etwas Geld haben
verbarrikadieren sie sich man richtet
erst Tore mit Telefonanlagen ein dann
kommt zu den Telefonanlagen Kameras man
baut Gitter denn wenn Sie heute die
Polizei anrufen dann kommt die leider
nicht weil sie immer überlastet ist
in der Anlage wohnen keine Superreichen
hier wohnen Busfahrer und Rentner auch
die sind bereit für etwas mehr
Sicherheit mehr zu zahlen
Dominik Remo freut sich über die neuen
Türschlösser mit Zugangscode Remo ist
konsumierter Polizist er wohnt mit
seiner Frau im siebten Stock
[Musik]
in der Zeitung lese ist es um die
Sicherheit in Marseille nicht gut
bestellt
vor allem im Süden der Stadt sind die
Viertel von Drogen durchzogen
hier bei uns im Viertel geht es ja noch
manchmal fühlt man sich mehr bedroht als
man es tatsächlich ist in Sachen
Sicherheit weiß der Wächter spielt sich
viel im Kopf ab
so wie mal eine Schranke nicht richtig
schließt rufen mich alle sofort an und
fragen wann wir sie reparieren die
machen sich Gedanken
die Leute fühlen sich mit Tor sicherer
es geht nur ums Gefühl man muss sich
klar machen dass das absolute Sicherheit
nicht gibt und doch versuchen Menschen
in Marseille alles mögliche und auch
unmögliche um sich etwas besser zu
fühlen Sarah Löffler wurde der Durchgang
gesperrt in ihrer eigenen Straße
arbeiten wir wurden zuvor nicht
informiert das war eine totale
Überraschung für uns
Nachbarn ließen die Straße kurzerhand
sperren für Autos und für Fußgänger mit
diesem Gitter dass ich nicht öffnen
lässt
für mich ist das ein physisches Symbol
der klassentrennung einer Teilung in der
Gesellschaft und die Botschaft die
Menschen wie mir und anderen die in
dieser Straße wohnen mitgeteilt wird ist
wir wollen nicht dass Ihr bei uns
vorbeigeht
Nachbarn die Nachbarn ausschließen wie
passt das zur Französischen Republik zu
Freiheit Gleichheit Brüderlichkeit
eine Ausstellung in der Bibliothek von
Marseille zeigt wie und warum mehr und
mehr Fläche der Stadt hinter Barrieren
verschwindet rot heißt nicht Bewohner
müssen draußen bleiben
[Musik]
viele Straßen marseills wurden im 19 und
20 Jahrhundert vom Großbürgertum
geschaffen dass das Gelände damals
aufgeteilt hat das waren Privatstraßen
und die Stadt wollte diese Straßen
damals nicht integrieren in das
öffentliche Straßennetz das sie
unterhalten musste wenn die Leute sie
heute schließen wollen dann haben Sie
das Recht dazu so
und wenn sie kein Recht dazu haben
schließen manche Wohnanlagen auch jede
Schranke die neu errichtet wird baut ein
Stück des Zusammenhalts ab Marseille
zerrieben zwischen Kriminalität und
Abschottung die Stadt versucht gegen zu
halten steht aber vor schwierigen
Aufgaben
wir haben eine Stadt in der sehr viel
illegal gebaut wurde ganze Gebäude ohne
Genehmigungen ich will dass alle sich an
Regeln halten mich also eingeschlossen
wenn jemand das Recht hat eine
Absperrung zu errichten dann werde ich
das nicht verhindern
so sind der Stadt die Hände gebunden bei
Neubauten kann sie etwas tun
künftig verweigern wir Genehmigungen für
Wohnanlagen die von Beginn an als
geschlossen geplant werden
so wird die Teilung erstmal weitergehen
nachmittags Schulschluss Regina holt
ihren Sohn der Angela ab sie hat sich
eigens einen Roller dafür gekauft
wir haben ein ganz schönes Stück vor uns
es dauert 20 25 Minuten
früher dauerte der Weg zu Fuß fünf
Minuten dann Schub sich die Mauer
zwischen Schule und zu Hause
da drüben wohnen wir
und dann geht es weiter vorbei an Toren
vorbei an Zäunen vorbei am Toren bis man
am Ende gar nicht mehr recht weiß ob die
Menschen in Marseille eigentlich aus
oder eingesperrt sind